in ukraine the russian-backed mayor in
the eastern city of donetsk is accusing
ukrainian forces of killing 13 people
after shelling the area two children are
said to be among the dead it follows a
similar attack on saturday which
officials say killed four people the
next city has been controlled by
russian-backed separatists since 2014.
it comes as ukraine's military says that
its troops have crossed a key river in
the northeast to regain lost territory
crossing the oskill river is significant
it may pave the way for an assault on
russian forces in the eastern donbass
region
in the past few weeks ukraine's
counter-offensive in the kharkiv and
kerason regions has gained momentum and
it's made some advances in luhansk let's
go live now to kiev al jazeera's gabe
alizondo is in the ukrainian capital
tell us more about the fighting game
what's the latest
it appears within the last 12 to 15
hours or so what we're now seeing is
another ukrainian counter-offensive this
one focused around the city of liman
it's a city of about 25 000 people
that's right on the front lines it's
been held
by russia for many months now and it
appears that uh
ukrainian forces are close to encircling
that town as part of this
counter offensive it's significant
because liman for two reasons is number
one
it is a home
to a major railroad axis for supply
lines and number two it's in don yes
danielska a region of the don bass so
what it's showing is is that the
ukrainians uh as part of their north
east counter-offensive retaking almost
all of the harakive region are now
pushing further east
and keeping the russians on the defense
encroaching upon more of the donbass
region of course the region that
vladimir putin said was key
for him
in terms of
taking all of luhansk and donesco
regions
in as part of this war and now it
appears uh that the ukrainians are very
much on the offensive in donetsk and
even in luhans an area that the russians
have pretty much controlled almost all
of for many months now it appears the
ukrainians are now starting to encroach
on that area too so this is a
counter-offensive round liman that we're
going to be watching very closely as the
ukrainians continue to seize the
offensive here and seize the momentum in
this war people are starting to ask
what would victory look like for the
ukrainians we went out and spoke to many
people here in kiev over the course of a
day and ask their opinions what does
victory look like for you this is what
they had to say
on a recent day in downtown kiev with
ukraine seizing the momentum we asked
people to define victory in the war
against russia
when our territory with crimea the
dumbass and curson will be ukrainian
again
when
all the russians occupiers will be back
to russia
maybe i'll be a little bit rude but i
hope maybe they will come back that
because they're killing our people
crimea for many here victory includes
reclaiming the southern peninsula
annexed by russia in 2014.
we need to
make the whole country free including
crimea
i know there are many people in the
european union which who still do not
believe in that
i believed and we believe that it
happens time pass
and
this happens
for some it's about joining military
alliances
in my opinion we have to join nato as
soon as possible only with the support
of our partners can we guarantee our
independence and well-being this war
made us stronger more powerful we
started to believe in ourselves more
and for others victory is about making
russia pay
[Music]
we have to reset our borders to where
they were in 1991 when we gained
independence from the soviet union but
victory is also when russia will pay
reparations to ukrainians to all those
who have lost their family and their
homes in this invasion
victory means a strong ukraine that
nobody will ever try to conquer again
the ukrainian military counter-offensive
that re-took the entire harkiv region
back from the russians certainly has
boosted morale but ukrainians also know
that with russia still in control of
about 75 percent of the donbass
more than half of zaparilla and all of
the herson region this very well could
be
a long war
in a country where for most the only
debate is not if ukraine eventually will
win
but what victory will look like when it
does gabe there are reports that russia
is
moving its naval assets in the black sea
what do we know about that
yeah it appears that with the important
uh black sea fleet of the russian navy
uh that is based in crimea crimea the
peninsula that
the russians have held since 2014 after
annexing it from ukraine that they have
moved according to uk intelligence some
of their nuclear-powered submarines from
the crimea region
to
the russian
port
about 500 kilometers away this is
significant because it would mean that
russia is trying to move some of their
black sea
uh fleet assets out of the range of
ukrainian missiles
missiles that and and drones that we
know have struck uh important parts of
uh the russian military uh uh uh
bases in the crimea region uh so if true
this would show that russia is at least
acknowledging that they are in range in
crimea of ukrainian missiles and trying
to move some of their black sleep sea
fleet assets out of that region to a
more safer area
on russian territory gabriel alexander
reporting live there from ukraine's
capital kiev gabe many thanks